but I want to just back up for a second
Deb you were talking about this
confrontation with shadow and there's a
really lovely quote from from young and
collected works fourteen that speaks to
this he says self-knowledge is an
adventure that carries us unexpectedly
far and deep even a moderately
comprehensive knowledge of the shadow
can cause a good deal of confusion and
mental darkness since it gives rise to
personality problems which one had never
remotely imagined before for this reason
alone we can understand why the
alchemist called their Negredo
melancholia a black blacker than black
so when we think about the darkness
versus the lightness or the black versus
the sunniness of the personality most of
us create a sense of self and a sense of
outer personality outer persona that
allows us to seem you know kind of
bright and appealing and congruent with
the norms of the culture and when the
Negredo when the shadow begins to roil
all of a sudden those pretty and nice
elements of the personality begin to
become challenged at the very least I'm
thinking about a lot of YouTube videos
running around of people lunging at
rolls of toilet paper and although I
mean that's become a point of comedy and
scorn at the same time if we think about
being one of those people racing to the
shelves to greedily or desperately grab
you know 48 rolls of toilet paper and
then later that day sitting down quietly
and thinking I'm that person I'm like
the person that elbowed the old lady to
grab the 48 rolls of toilet paper and
scurry them into my car and asking where
do I put that image of myself and yet
there it is I'm thinking of a sort of
fictionalized case here you know if
someone who maybe is mid-career and
and very well-established and finds that
you know partly as a result of the
disruption of pandemic he falls in love
with his colleague who's much junior and
and you know this has never been
something he would ever have thought
would happen and he is this was never in
his value system to cheat on his wife or
have an affair and and this is you know
sort of the wrong thing to do for all
kinds of reasons and yet he he just is
sort of tempest-tossed with these wild
desires that seem to be propelling him
to go in this completely new direction
that is like a Negredo place and it has
to do with the dissolution of old forms
things that you used to work and hold us
up and contain us and give us direction
and meaning now suddenly just feel like
they've been swept away or they've been
melted down and we're left really
confronting ourselves and wondering who
the heck are we I think that speaks so
poignant ly to exactly what a
confrontation with shadow feels like
whether it's your example Joseph of the
person that scoops up lots and lots of
toilet paper in desperation or or greed
or whatever it is and then what do we do
with that later or your personal ISA who
has to realize that there's an
attraction that doesn't really fit with
what he thought was his morality system
know that there's a death of our
illusion about who we thought we were
that ties in to what you talked about
Joseph the persona I'm a nice person I'm
good to people I feed my cat I do you
know all these nice things then then
what really were called to do is when we
get home that night or home from the
grocery store is to confront that part
of ourselves that is not what I want it
to be I look at what
have done of what I have said this
illicit or seemingly illicit
relationship the hoarding of whatever it
might have been from the grocery store
that is part of who I am
I think that's me yeah it's the way that
realizing you're really having to own
your shadow just kind of melts you down
it is a real and terrible
disillusionment then I am not all those
things that I thought I was and the the
point isn't to necessarily remonstrate
with oneself of our G I really shouldn't
have done that
oh the the point is to come to terms
with that as an internal reality so that
it doesn't have to be enacted of the
Union says we all have a thief and a
trickster and probably a murderer and
all these really dark things within but
if we can give them a place at the table
of consciousness then we are
paradoxically freed up from having to
enact all these things in the outer
world I agree with you Deb and having
sat with someone who you know my
fictionalized case you know I have sat
with people going through things like
that and I just want to say that it's
easy to jump to well if we just give it
a place at the table then we won't have
to act it out but when when you're
caught in this and you really really say
want to leave your wife and go have the
affair with the junior colleague you
really are suffering it and there is no
shortcut I think at our chemical image
that really captures that and I think
it's one of the rows areum images is a
vibrant muscular green lion that is
chomping and eating the Sun and saliva
is dripping down from its mouth
and that's a depiction of raw powerful
instinctive energies that have the
capacity to take hold of the ego and
gobble it down like sink its teeth into
it that it's not a pretty process it's
not an abstracted process but it feels
like being chewed up by the passion to
have an affair with the junior colleague
or grabbing and hoarding things because
we feel that our survival suddenly
depends on it and we've always been a
rather refined or elegant person any
number of other behaviors and there's
this terrible behavior that's happening
where if somebody appears to be not
complying with social distancing this
vigilante attitude is springing up in
communities and individuals are
harassing people like screaming at them
if they're not following what the
authority figures in the culture are
telling them what to do so this kind of
shadow bullying is rising up in the
culture now one of the things that we do
first when shadow rises is we often
defend against it oh that's not me
sometimes we'll literally forget that we
did something because it's sowing
congruent with our view of ourselves
sometimes within moments we're
projecting it onto another person and
saying they're the one that's doing it I
didn't do that
but the Negredo begins when we have to
put hands on the experience and if the
Negredo is navigated successfully at the
end we can say I am that I am everything
I have been but I am also that